ooh in scared-straight news y'all watch
that show I love ya I love it oh it's go
straight this [ __ ] that the jail thing
right
Oh [ __ ] love that show a nation became
to jail basically and they just start
like spitting into the world like Oh pop
pockets like what yeah hold my pockets
dude
they literally flipped out his pocket
and he said hold my pocket some crazy
jail [ __ ] that's just I'm holdin up my
shirt [ __ ] they said take your shoes
off and he was like where anyone we put
him he said oh they mine now they like
prison threats and lingo is [ __ ]
insane it's like a different world like
I kind of want to know what all that
[ __ ] because they're so creative with
that yeah you mean like the way they
thought about it yeah they got like a
[ __ ] piece of paper now hold my
pocket like uh he's like he's he calls
himself a warrior and he's like he loves
a man's butt like he finds it so
irresistible he responsible he goes up
to guys he's like look I like you and I
want you we could do this the easy way
or the hard way I like you and I won't
[ __ ] we could do it is the easy way or
the hard way that's world
I love booty that's what it was talking
about the whole sagging culture that's
like yeah yeah he says he thinks it's
sexy he goes a man he's like a man's
butt is more valuable than water the way
he expresses it though like oh he only
needs to say a man's butt you know
exactly what he's thinking yeah the
funny part is like the documentarian
he's like sir so are you gay and then
his face was like are you [ __ ] gay I
just like man's booty yes
like in prison like you can [ __ ] a guy
and then you're still not gay I don't
know what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is I don't
know what that means
that's just survival problem yeah pretty
much okay [ __ ] them cuz I had to to
prove what was hard
alright submitted by for he was hard
what cool of Florida parents are calling
on a scare for hire clown to get their
children to behave a clown why do
parents do that why do they rely on
other [ __ ] people to like fix their
[ __ ] problems cuz easier probably
create cuz it takes a village to go
alright you're gonna see when Tiger gets
older and he's like making you pull out
your hair we're gonna be hiring clowns
probably alright or the neighborhood
shows the clown
it's this retired divorced man from
Rhode Island we don't know his true
identity because you doesn't want to
reveal it played 60 five years old he
moved to Florida for the warmer climate
and he somehow he just decided you know
what I want to dress up as a creepy
clown I really like it [ __ ] this guy and
so he goes by the name of wrinkles oh no
that's great wrinkles the class makes me
want to put a bat to his face yeah he
makes you want to run in the opposite No
oshri nobody you I [ __ ] will pay my
taxes back any money I owe anybody in
this room I'll pay that back to you
gives you goosebumps his face looks like
a tribal ball sack dude yo his face
looks like elephantitis what the [ __ ]
look at his chin that looks like nuts
he's face so big I mean that's great
oh is it I thought it was legit his face
no good you know like old people get
that old saggy skin no yeah no no he is
far away from the screen yeah come on
farts bar just come on relax it really
does look like a really old person
though just has a lot of makeup what if
it is his real face that we're all like
it's a mask
no let's get that lets get that fixed
first he looks scary
yeah edgy yeah so you see his phone has
been blowing up like people have been
wanting to hire him parents need help
not only parents were like he'll get
hired for some like freaky people a
Marilyn Manson they want to do hey can
you wear that while you [ __ ] me yeah
there you go home well he does he does
get requests like weird ass [ __ ] and
like apparently one of them was like
someone was trying to hire him to get
rid of a body or some [ __ ] but he
obviously declines those what do you
think I have a [ __ ] criminal you
think I am [ __ ] scary clown I'm not a
murderer plus he's very visible no you
did it he's gonna come in a big-ass
unicycle
I don't know though you remember like a
year ago when those clowns are walking
around and everybody was scared oh yeah
forgot about that
that was a [ __ ] thing what the [ __ ]
come on big in mind is like a clown hit
man now it's like when you see the red
balloon fly up that means my jobs
complete it oh my god I didn't see the
new it movie did you guys see it
[ __ ] me never we don't she doesn't want
to watch anything scary wind yugioh he
start did you hear that he said we and
he's like I'm no [ __ ] no so like I'm
different than you because I I get
scared but I'm curious so I still want
to watch I just want to watch
watch it with the blanket I want to
watch with the blanket I want but he's
still trying to prove to you he's not a
[ __ ] saamana I know about this can I
have a blanket but I'm still down to
watch I'm just curious [ __ ] so we were
like we were like we're gonna be brave
tonight and it was nighttime and we're
gonna be breaking out we're gonna watch
Murray right yeah and then we're on
Netflix you know it shows you like the
bots like the title the janitor yeah the
picture of what the movies like so just
looking at that I got scared he's like
yeah yeah we're doing you got scared
from the title little thumbnails yeah
the movie covers like what level is
scary and the whole [ __ ] genre scary
so I mean what what consists of this is
too scary
and then this is okay nothing is okay
thrillers I think get out is like where
I'm like comfortable I'm like oh I'm
like all right this is cool like there's
some freaky part so no horror but you're
done with thrillers because you know the
slashers don't scare me
corpses yeah you're like on my level
type of [ __ ] which means that we're okay
with like murderers [ __ ] I'm not okay
with murder we're not good with my
paranormal stuff i'm leavin' worse with
that one I'm not okay with murder
have you seen the house of 1000 corpses
what's that about Rob Zombie flick oh
they're going to like this town and then
in that town they're like they're like
cannibals and they're just crazy-ass
people Oh [ __ ] creepy is just like
people I'm okay with it
because that just means I just got shoot
everything in sight but if it's like
ghosts and paranormal [ __ ] yeah it makes
me feel weak my shoulders like like if I
turn this TV off and that [ __ ] could
start happening right now
oh well watch it like if I were watch
Paranal night TV by myself and I turn
the TV off and then the door starts
shutting and stuff like that could
actually happen I'm what about black
mirror stuff is that too scary I haven't
watched enough that's not scary for her
like I feel like that you might be okay
with is bad if you watch it with him
you'll be okay so I was trying to watch
Human Centipede and she didn't want to
watch it that's disgusting looking yeah
I mean they get vivisected okay that
word itself is terrifying it is horrific
you know what's weird with me like my
laziness has reached a level to the
point where I don't get that scared
anymore
Vanessa she was creeped out because she
thought that I was like blowing on her
neck but I was sitting across her she
goes what the [ __ ] was that I was a
pretty talk about she goes who the [ __ ]
is blowing my neck I was I didn't
[ __ ] do it and then she felt it again
and then when she got up the [ __ ]
light above her started flickering right
and I looked at that I was like I'm just
gonna Norton know what you mean I'm so
tired now too like before I wouldn't
walk into a dark room like I have to
have a life but I'm so exhausted that
I'm just like [ __ ] it I don't know I'm
pretty sure there's like a ghost or a
specter that's hanging around her but
I'm gonna ignore you he's got a went and
moved on with it
I've got videos to edit [ __ ] yeah
someone else we got [ __ ] [ __ ] to
worry about right now man so I have the
CCTV footage yeah I love these here we
go oh [ __ ] how does he fit in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god that is some scary ass
all OH
good morning that's a good voice is that
the it boys you can it sounds like that
no good a little good morning time yeah
my [ __ ] that kids still sleepy doesn't
give a [ __ ] they're putting the blanket
over the face wait why did he turn off
the camera
from even though I'm not a parent but
from a parenting standpoint that's PTSD
inducing you can't do that shitty kids
I'd rather beat my kids versus give them
mental damage that be [ __ ] house
misbehaving you can watch this video
it's on YouTube but there's this
Japanese show where there's a lady she's
like please help me my kids don't sleep
she has like four [ __ ] kids that just
go crazy every night and she's alright
if you don't go to sleep the zombies
gonna come get you and they're like yeah
bees and then a zombie comes over and
then tells a little sleep attack them
ready
I don't know what it was about cuz I can
understand it but although that's the
other one okay that's them being like if
they'll really like fight and say what
they you know they say but another one
is is like a trouble bunch of kids and
then and then the zombies like go to
sleep and in the kids like then the moms
just cracking up who just people are so
[ __ ] dope they don't give a [ __ ]
about PTSD man there is no such thing as
pts for this CCTV footage so they filmed
it on their home security camera
but the little girl grant Lee actually
didn't really wake up but then they save
that footage a shortage people show it
to her later and be like AV keep
misbehaving it's common to come back
that's [ __ ] up Oh super [ __ ] up even
if she didn't see it in person but just
seeing the footage of it that's [ __ ]
scary she's not sleeping every no cuz I
got help no I got so scared when I'm
Isaac was little and he told me that
there was a little girl over me when he
would try to come near me that she would
go he told me that she and I packed all
my stuff cause he was at my sister's
house in Mexico I packed all my [ __ ] and
I went to my grandma's house I'm like
[ __ ] that and that's just hearing it
imagine seeing in hell no [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dude if my kid tells me I stuff adoption
instantly good get the [ __ ] out of my
house it was like I've been bonded with
you yet I know I have a bonded yet you
didn't sleep on my chest when you came
out the [ __ ] hey [ __ ] off me
[Music]